hello everyone and welcome to a game
that's really going to improve your
saturday and if you're a king's indian
player it's going to improve it even
more it's a game uh that came as a
suggestion on twitter from a user named
j certified comedian trademark
and it's a game between one man army 93
and hikaru nakamura one man army 93 i
don't know who it is but it is a grand
master from the united states and his
blitz rating on chess.com is over 2900
so it's uh definitely someone we know
but i myself don't know who it is
there's nothing on the account so if any
of you do know do share so we can uh all
get uh some info on that but the game
itself is really awesome so without
further ado let's check it out uh mr one
man army with a photo of bobby fischer
as his profile photo uh plays d4 uh we
have knight to f6 by hikaru c for uh g6
knight to c3 and now bishop to g7 going
for the king's indian
defense
and uh aside from uh aside from let's
say gary kasparov hikaru nakamura is uh
well one of the fiercest players ever to
play the the kings indian
we have e4 and now d6
preparing to develop the light square
bishop also keeping an eye on the e5
square and now f3 going for the samish
variation uh against the king's indian
we have castles by hikaru and bishop to
e3 we have e5 now striking in the center
d5 wide grabs more space and now the
immediate knight to h5 making room uh
for the queen to enter the game if
needed also you can play f5 uh so it
definitely makes sense to get this
knight
uh to the edge of the board even uh if
only temporarily we have queen to d2 now
not allowing any knight to f4 ideas also
maybe preparing uh queen side castles
and now uh usually uh f5 is the move
that's being played here that's the the
most common move but hikaru plays queen
to h for check so what can white do here
well white will of course block the
check with with the g3 he says uh thank
you for the
um uh well just the developing my pieces
uh and now uh he car replaced something
that's uh incredibly awesome uh this
this position has been reached in a
world chess championship match uh
against uh no other than gary kasparov
and donald truly karpov it was karpov
actually who had the white pieces here
and after karpov played the g3 kasparov
retreated with queen to e7 yeah it was
their 1990 uh world champs championship
match that was played in london in new
york this is i believe game 22
uh and kasparov retreated with queen to
e7 and this is the absolute strongest
move according to engine so kasparov uh
played it well but karpov was the one
who won that game but this is not a
classical game in the world chase
championship this is a blitz game online
so car just plays knight captures on g3
and of course you can't capture with the
h pawn because the rook would hang on h1
but what you can play is queen to f2 and
this is what one man army 93 plays you
could also play bishop to f2 uh but
that's not as great because after knight
captures an f1 the white queen will also
be attacked so black would be better
here so instead we have queen to f2 and
now how do you continue again knight
captures on f1 here hikaru sacrifices a
queen queen captures on h4 and now
knight captures an e3 with the threat of
knights to c to check just winning the
rook on a1 as well so we have to prevent
this with king to e2 now attacking the
knight and knight captures on c4 so
basically uh what do you get here for
sacrificing your queen well you get the
the bishop's pair and a pawn which uh is
not all that bad a bishop pair uh you
know if used properly can be just as
strong or stronger than a queen remember
that uh bobby fischer game against ben
larson in the candidates matches 1971.
so here b3 chasing away the knight
knight to b6 and now knight to h3 going
for some knight to g5 ideas maybe queen
can attack h7 maybe night can come to e6
uh and now you can't really develop the
knight naturally via knight to d7 to f6
if you play this knight b5 is very
annoying so uh instead after knight to
h3 we have knights to a6 by hikaru uh
and now rook h the g1
we have bishop to d7 just continuing
development and now there is one game
where rook 8 d1 was played in the
database but here we have knight
f2 and it is only now as of move 16 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how hikaru continues he continues
with f5 the white king is in the center
of the board and we want to open up
lines and more importantly we have the
bishop pair so we really want to open up
lines uh black uh has two bishops and
two knights whereas white only has two
knights so white would enjoy a closed
position where the
bishop ferry is useless but hikaru of
course will try to open up the position
and now white even helps him with that
maybe here knight to h3 to g5
has some merit but like i said it's a
blitz game we're not going to
overanalyze it so he captures on f5 rook
captures on f5 now hikaru has a very
natural way of developing his other rook
we have knight f to e4 and now rook a to
f8 putting pressure on the f3 pawn and
now again it's always a question whether
knight to g5 can be played or not but uh
first we have rook a2f1 defending the
pawn and now rook to f4 hikaru chases
away the white queen queen to e1 and now
bishop to f5 so what do you play here uh
h4 here white wants to open up
some lines in front of the black king so
he can start using his rooks for attack
but now knight to b4 and here hikaru is
already uh preparing some devilish
trickery so to say as the knight
captures an a2 would would definitely go
a long way for example if white just
continues h5 we can play knight captures
on a2 and then it's not easy to defend
this if you just capture the knight for
example it's game over just bishop
captures on e4
and
white's defenses have been completely
shattered of course if pawn captures
then rook captures then it's game over
white will not do this but uh there's
very little white could do here so queen
to d2 keeping an eye on this um uh pawn
here and now uh c6 you could also maybe
play bishop to h6 and try and take
advantage of this awkward positioning of
the white queen but okay we have c6
first d captures knight captures and now
queen captures on d6 so now the white
queen is incredibly active here but uh
maybe there is not all that much to do
here hikaru plays rook to d8 with queen
to c5 and now knight the d4 with check
and now uh you have to play king the e1
here to continue playing the game but
that's for uh uh
for a longer time format to analyze here
king the e3 was played and now the
position is winning for hikaru but you
have to
pause the video first and try to find
the winning idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this move
where there are so many great candidate
moves and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is rook the c8
going after the queen and the problem is
yes the c3 knight is defended but that
doesn't really matter so here even if
white tries to really keep an eye on
this c3 knight we would still find let's
say bishop to h6 now threaten all sorts
of very nasty discoveries uh and well
once you block this let's say knight to
g5 now we can even play rook captures on
c3 with czech queen captures a knight to
d5 check uh a nice uh queen winning fork
here just wins the game for black so
instead after rook to see it we have
queen to d6 uh and now he car just plays
bishop captures on e4 and now it's not
much better if you play knight captures
on e4 just knights to f5 another queen
winning fork uh so after bishop captures
an e4 we have f captures an e for
keeping an eye on the f5 square but now
hikaru just plays rook captures on c3
with check you couldn't defend
everything came to d2 and now rook c to
f3 now threatening rook captures on f1
so rook to d1 is played and now finally
bishop to h6 the problem is the white
queen is completely useless here in
doing some damage so what can you play
here yeah you could try this rook
capture some g6 idea with um sort of a
sort of sort of a checkmating attack
let's say rook to g1 but there's always
rook to f7 so you don't really have to
worry about that so instead after bishop
to h6 we have rook to g5 blocking the
bishop's diagonal this way but now he
car just captures he is up too much
material h captures and g5 rook captures
on e4 and now this king is wide open and
you know uh
it's uh
it's game over for white king to c1
trying to get some uh coverage but uh
rook to e2 now with the idea of just
rook captures on a2 knight captures on
b3 and that's that's it basically so
rook captures on d4 was played e
captures on d4 and queen to b8 to check
but now the simplest way to win is
actually a forced checkmate and that's
rook to f8 uh andy was in this position
on move 35 that uh our mystery man one
man army 93 resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here you're
either losing the queen or you're
trading for a rook or you play something
like queen captures on b7 and it's
checkmate in one because the the rooks
uh well uh there's no escape from from a
rook pair
uh so after rook to f8 uh one man army
93 resigned and what an amazing victory
for hikaru nakamura now it's not a it's
not a new idea to sacrifice this queen
but if you haven't seen it before and
especially if you enjoy playing the
king's indian defense you might use it
in some of your own games uh if it's a
serious game then maybe going for after
g3 kasparov's move against carp of queen
to e7 is the way to go but if it's a fun
game you know in
against a friend in a bar or a library
knight captures and g3 will get you an
incredibly enjoyable game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh thank you again mr
certified comedian for suggesting it uh
i would like to thank matthias binta uh
zachary bell michael marin
vast knowledge and the dewey guy for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
whatever else is happening in the chess
world we have a very nice tournament
starting today checking up of course on
your wonderful suggestions and uh pretty
much everything else uh so thank y'all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day